el objetivo principal es el de seguir
ejerciendo presión sobre la asamblea
nacional que justamente tiene hasta
mañana a la medianoche para terminar de
estudiar el proyecto de ley de esta
reforma laboral y sobre todo lo que
quieren es que se pueda al fin discutir
del artículo siete que es el principal
es el que hace que se aumente la edad
laboral la edad pensional de 62 a 64
años por ahora esos debates han sido
bastante
agitados y poco se ha podido digamos ir
adelantando en ese debate Así que ese es
uno de los objetivos El otro es de
seguir demostrándole al gobierno la
inconformidad de los franceses con esta
idea de esta reforma pensional a pesar
de que hoy no debe haber mucha gente en
las calles para manifestar Porque en
buena parte del país está en plenas
vacaciones escolares aquí en París no
estarán Los líderes de los sindicatos
ellos van a marchar en albies es una
ciudad al suroeste del país tiene 50.000
habitantes Espera que 30.000 de ellos
salgan a las calles y por supuesto como
usted bien lo decía en la introducción
quizás otro de los puntos más
importantes del día de hoy es no
solamente ejercer presión sino también
ser un poco el preámbulo antes de ese
siete de marzo esa jornada negra en
donde ya todos los sindicatos están
llamando a bloquear el país